and it's what a privilege for me to get
to be here and in this beautiful space
now it's a little dangerous to let me in
the pulpit I must say I'm am I'm a
Methodist Sunday school teacher in
backwoods backwoods Methodist Church it
would several of them would fit in this
nice building and and the UM you don't
have to the illogical training is
minimal it must be said if ones capable
of taking a tea towel on Christmas Eve
and turning a fourth grader into a
Palestinian Shepherd then you're pretty
much that's about all the qualifications
you need um but Sunday School teachers
you know spend much of their time down
in the basement while all the good
stuffs going on upstairs so I think we
suffer from a kind of pulpit Envy in a
way and the point of which is I may be
here for a while okay it's a tremendous
honor most of all to be giving this
first lecture in honor of professor
colistin one of those people because of
whom the world is palpably different
than it would have been otherwise which
is not something that can be said of all
our most people and a very profound
thing indeed to be able to say and it's
a pleasure for me because his work and
this sort of almost historical accidents
that it wandered in to coincide nicely
with much of the things that much many
of the topics that I work on some time
around 50 years ago with rachel carson
and then with all that followed in its
wake we began to wake up to the idea
that perhaps progress wasn't quite as
perfectly shiny as we adhere to fork
thought it would be that modernity was
tainted in certain ways and that we were
going to have to take that taint into
considerable calculation at
as we move forward so with Rachel Carson
or then with the understanding of things
like Agent Orange with the very you know
fact of our misadventure in Vietnam
ramified on into our following
subsequent misadventures around the
world with the advent of our ability to
genetically manipulate organisms before
we devolved any particular sense about
where or when that might be appropriate
um to to make no mistake about it the
very related set of financial failures
that we now see a dominating our
headlines for the moment in a sense much
of the enterprise of modernity is called
into more and more serious question by
this chain of events and most of all as
I will spend most of this talk
describing by the almost inconceivable
crisis now breaking over our heads
because of the changes in the
temperature of the planet all these
things in a sense share a common theme
and it's in some ways appropriate that
we're here today to talk about it
because in a way it's an almost
theological theme this idea that in very
short order in the lifetimes of people
in this room humans have gotten very
very big all of a sudden extremely big
able to cast a very long shadow and
we've gotten big too fast before we
could figure out what the consequences
of that we're going to be maybe since
we're in church you'll forgive me if I
am appeal for a moment to my favorite
book in the Bible book of Job in the
Hebrew Bible um one of the first great
modern stories in a sense because it's
ambiguous but it's also one of the most
first great piece of nature writing in
the Western tradition and perhaps the
most beautiful of all you all know the
story of course job is a fine fellow and
he's suddenly inexplicably cursed in his
flocks died and his family dies and he
finds himself living on a dung heap at
the edge of town covered with oozing
sores things are not going well in his
world and contrary to the patient job of
legend he's in fact much the opposite
very impatient and very demanding and
keeps insisting that God appeared to
explain why this has happened to him you
know give me some justifications keeps
out on to you you sinned or your
children see no no you know that
conventional wisdom today is not good
enough to explain this turn of events I
want God to appear and tell me justify
himself this turns out to fall into the
category of be careful what you wish for
in a way because God does appear um and
speaking out of the voice of a whirlwind
delivers a long soliloquy now there are
actual theologians here so somebody
correct me if i'm wrong i think it's the
longest speech that God gives anywhere
in the bible old testament or new okay
and unbelievably beautiful it's a sort
of tour of the physical universe and and
and and and of all the wild creatures
that there could be and very
biologically accurate and sexy and
crunchy and and and just magnificent
piece of writing I particularly
recommend the stephen mitchell
translation that north point press
published some years ago a magnificent
piece of writing but it's also
unbelievably sarcastic okay it's like
the taunt god keeps saying who are you
you know if you're so smart do you know
where i keep the the storms can you
whistle up a hurricane you know do you
tell the proud waves where to break this
just goes on and on and on very
sarcastic and
and quite powerful since it's God
talking to you you're no taunting a
certain point job just basically says
sorry I asked you know and and and and
sits down and that's sort and and more
or less that's been the relationship of
human beings to the natural world for
most of our career we're in a small part
of something very large and as God
explains in this soliloquy quite
beautiful and orderly and meaningful and
mysterious and cruel and and and and
magnificent okay we don't get to say
what joe says you know we don't get to
just sit down we get to answer right
back because we're big now okay we're
extremely large and the best proof of
that largeness is what the first proof
of that largeness of course was 60 years
ago with the ability to contemplate
all-out nuclear war and what that would
mean for the planet but we've averted
that so far um um the best proof of it
in real time is the ongoing climate saga
now unfolding I wrote the first book for
a general audience about global warming
20 years ago the time it was still a
hypothesis I thought it's very strong
one the science was very clear okay the
molecular structure of co2 we know
enough about to know that it traps heat
that would otherwise radiate back out to
space since we were burning enough coal
and gas and oil to put lots of co2 into
the atmosphere it seemed in many ways
quite clear what the outcome would be
but it also seemed emotionally
counterintuitive how could we have
gotten large enough to be affecting
everything that happened on the surface
of the earth because that's what we're
talking about every process that we see
evaporation precipitation wind speed
progress of the seasons you know on and
on and on draws its energy from that
increment of the sun's energy trapped in
our narrow envelope of Atmos
they're the only exceptions are tectonic
and volcanic forces everything else on
the surface that comes from the Sun well
to kind of get over that different that
sort of impossibility factor you know
science went to work and went to work
with more diligence and more money and
more resources than really had ever
tackled any similar sized problem in a
similar period of time incredibly
powerful body of work and of course the
point of that work the scientific
dialectic being what it is was to prove
that the hypothesis was wrong you know
to take down this idea by 1995 it was
very clear that that wasn't going to
happen and that a strong consensus had
emerged within the community that
climate change was very real and very
serious it was a kind of wake-up call
you are that big you know and now we're
going to deal with consequences the time
since 1995 it's as if the planet itself
has been peer reviewing that research
just to make sure that it was correct
okay we've had all 10 of the warmest
years on record since then and it's
become abundantly clear that this
hypothesis is completely true y'all are
completely up to date on that part of
the story I know maybe I just want to
extend for a minute here just to sort of
bring you right to where we are at the
moment because in the last couple of
years 18 months that hypothesis that
turned to consensus has actually turned
again to a kind of panic um as we begin
to understand that these changes are
happening on a larger scale and much
more quickly than we had anticipated
okay the signal event in this
realization was probably the rapid melt
of Arctic ice in the summer of 2007 ice
has been melting steadily for 40 years
but only by one or two percent on
average a year okay the minimum extent
of Isis increasing timber and ice began
to reform there was twenty-five percent
less than they'd ever been before that
was repeated last summer for a while
last summer both the Northwest
northeast passages were wide open you
could circumnavigate the Arctic on open
water never happened in human history
and long before human history now that's
scary because it's proof that we're
warming the planet there's no other
explanation for what's going on but it's
also scary because it reminds us that
this is a process that can get easily
completely out of control that there are
feedback loops embedded in the system
that are very dangerous so that nice
white ice sheet across the Arctic
reflects eighty percent of incoming
solar radiation back out to space okay
it's a mirror useful thing in this case
you remove it and replace it with blue
water that absorbs eighty percent of
that incoming radiation this heat the
scientists would call it Arctic
amplification is now well underway and
the heat signal stretches 1500
kilometers inland from the ocean now and
one of the results of that is that we're
seeing very rapid rise in the melt rate
of Baton drah the permafrost and it
turns out that trapped beneath that
permafrost there's another global
warming gas methane ch4 that suddenly
spiking in the atmosphere in very large
quantities as I mean they're scientists
who in the last two years have been
describing Siberia the coldest place in
the northern hemisphere pointing out
that even at 40 below ponds and streams
and things aren't freezing because
there's so much methane bubbling up from
beneath that it's keeping them open as
the year goes along those are scary
because it adds to the volume of
heat-trapping gas in the atmosphere but
what's scary really about it is that at
a certain point we're not directly doing
it we create the conditions by burning
coal and gas and oil and putting carbon
in the atmosphere to set off these chain
of reactions but past a certain point
we're not in control of it anymore so
that even if we did everything right and
stopped burning that coal and gas and
oil very quickly it's by now an open
question as to how long that melt will
continue and what that you know whether
or not
be able to rain this system back in we
have a number finally to express this
and this is this most important number
in the world that I've been describing
um it came from our foremost
climatologists NASA team in in January
of 2008 led by Jim Hansen they published
a paper in which they said the 350 parts
per million co2 was the most that we
could have in the atmosphere for any
long period of time if we wish to retain
as they put it in the abstract of a
peer-reviewed scientific paper if we
wish to maintain a planet similar to the
one on which civilization developed into
which life on Earth is adapted okay so
350 a new number nobody knew it you know
even 18 months ago and it's a really
important number it turns out to be one
of those fundamental things about the
earth that's worth knowing in sort of
the same way that it's worth knowing
that the proper temperature of your body
is 98.6 or something like that so you
have some baseline against which to
judge before the Industrial Revolution
the atmospheric concentration of co2 was
275 parts per million plus or minus 10
parts per million for 10,000 years okay
and this stability in the atmosphere
underwrote the climatic stability that
is marked human civilization at 10,000
years of the Holocene it's been
remarkably stable time and a good one to
be building the kind of scale of
civilization that we've built we began
to raise that number above 275 with the
Industrial Revolution we began to pour
carbon into the atmosphere but we never
knew where the red line was right we
didn't know exactly where the danger but
this was a big experiment in sort of the
same way that you know introducing
defoliants into the biosphere was an
experiment know where the red line was
okay in fact at first the number we
tossed around 20 years ago a lot was 550
parts per million
because we had any real idea that this
was the danger point no because it was
twice what it used to be and hence
relatively easy to model on a computer
okay and with the way that sort of
things like that I can show you lots of
charts with people and drawn red lines
at 500 we began to understand that was
too high finally now we have this real
number to work with the trouble is it's
one hell of a tough number okay we're
already past it we're at 387 parts per
million and rising two parts per million
per annum at the moment we're like we're
not like the guy who goes to the doctor
and the doctor says off you know if you
keep up this cheese eating habit of
yours someday your cholesterol will be
too high you know um we're like the guy
who goes the doctor and doctor says look
we're going to have a talk right now
your cholesterol is too high and if it
stays in this zone as long as it's in
this zone your chance of having a heart
attack or a stroke is really good and
you better hope you can get it down
before that heart attack or stroke
happens well that's where we are as a
planet and those heart attacks and
strokes are starting to happen that's
why the Arctic is melting okay and it's
why lots and lots of other things are
going on warm air holds more water vapor
than cold air does a useful fact to keep
in mind it means that in every arid
place around the world we're seeing
remarkable increases in evaporation and
hence in drought and drought on an epic
scale in fact the Australian reader
Meteorological Office said a few weeks
ago that they're no longer going to use
the term drought to describe what's
going on because as they put it drought
implies that it may come to an end at
some point okay it clearly from what
they can tell isn't the tropics the
meteorological tropics have expanded in
the last 15 years about two degrees
north and two degrees south okay and
that's pushed the dry subtropics that
much further out north and south and now
that accounts for some of that dryness
across that continent
and not just Australia the US government
has said much the same thing about the
American Southwest in fact most
hydrologists now think that Lake Powell
the great huge lake formed behind Glen
Canyon Dam on the Colorado River will
never fill again that is that the rate
of evaporation is now high enough and
the rate of virgin streamflow on the
upper Colorado low enough that it'll
just slowly sink over time and within 10
or 15 years may be entirely empty once
that water's up in the air it's going to
come down someplace and that's what's
happening in every wet place in the
world tremendous delusion flood at this
latitude we see about a twenty five
percent increase in the number of storms
that drop two inches of rain in a
24-hour period the kind of gully washers
that do nobody any good that make it
very hard to farm that you know go on
and on and on we see big changes in
storminess I'm going to be in New
Orleans tomorrow at Tulane talking with
people who have you know dealt firsthand
with the consequences of what it means
when you begin to amp up these systems
hurricanes draw their power from the
heat in the first few meters of the Seas
surface and we are now seeing we think
more and definitely more intense
hurricanes than we've seen in the past
okay so 350 is an incredibly important
number the most important number we have
because you would you pass that sign I'm
just you'll see in a minute I'm trying
to learn to be an organizer of sorts I'm
very bad at it but um there's a sign-up
sheet going around that if you want to
be informed and help in this work that
I'm going to be describing I hope
they'll give us your your name and email
address would be very useful the point
I'm trying to make is that this is no
longer a question for people's children
and grandchildren okay and it's no
longer some abstract threat that's
coming at us someday when this is what's
happening here and now it's not absurd
just the same way that once those
discoveries about defoliants and sui
beans turned into Agent Orange there was
suddenly no abstraction about them and
one had to go take action and make
something happen so now for me that
moment came that moment of just sort of
snapping came in a trip to Bangladesh
they're probably people here who've been
to Bangladesh it's one of the most
beautiful countries on earth incredibly
fertile a very tolerant and wonderful
Muslim culture one of my favorite places
on earth very crowded 140 million people
in an area the size of Wisconsin but it
feeds itself its food self-sufficient
because the great sacred rivers of Asia
the Ganges and the Brahmaputra come
pouring down out of the Himalayas and
they flood gently out over this Delta
there in leave behind leave behind a
layer of silt and things just explode
out of the ground so they can feed
themselves but they're completely
screwed okay a those rivers come out of
the glaciers high in the Himalayas
there's an area the size of Italy up in
Tibet where glaciers form the headwaters
of the Yangtze the yellow the Ganges the
Brahmaputra the Mekong and the so lean
those glaciers are melting fast and many
of them may be gone by mid-century okay
one-third of human beings live
downstream from those glaciers and they
don't just live there by accident that's
why they live there one of the great
features of the Holocene was that it was
warm enough that there wasn't a sheet of
ice above the continental interiors and
we could grow grain but it was cold
enough that there was this permanent
snowpack in the Andes in the Himalayas
in the Sierras okay there's no plan B
for what happens down below you know if
when those melt meanwhile the Bay of
Bengal is rising and will rise much more
another useful physical principle to
keep in mind is that warm water takes up
more space than cold that alone will be
enough that thermal
pansion to raise the sea level a couple
of feet this entry and we now think it's
going to be considerably higher than
that because it looks like Greenland and
the West Antarctic ice sheets are not as
stable as we'd assumed them to be even a
few years ago people are now tossing
around numbers like five six seven feet
of sea level rise in the course of this
century those are civilization
challenging numbers and no place more
obvious than along the badman gone but
those are relatively chronic problems
when I was there they were suffering
from a very acute problem they're having
their first big outbreak of a disease
called dengue fever all right a
mosquito-borne disease that the World
Health Organization says will be the
emergent disease of this century because
the mosquito that spreads it Edie's
Egypt I is remarkably sensitive to
changes in heat and humidity and expands
its range rapidly and indeed we've seen
increases in incidence of 200 300 400
percent across south america and asia so
far this decade last year in brazil they
did an outbreak so bad that the military
was opening field hospitals across the
interior because emergency rooms were
reporting 400 cases an hour arriving at
their doors okay this having their first
big outbreak in dhaka the city in
bangladesh 14 million when i was there
and i was spending a lot of time in the
slum so i got bit by the wrong mosquito
and i came down with dengue myself all
right well you know obviously I didn't
die um a lot of people did die they were
younger than me or older than me or
sicker than me or poorer than me to
begin with and so not able to deal with
this I remember going to the hospital in
Dhaka big Ward cops stretching as far as
you can see people lying on each cot
shivering this is a nasty disease they
called breakbone fever it's unpleasant
in the extreme and it of course it has
those you know sweats and then chilled
people just look and there's people on
the floor between the cots cos aren't
enough cause i remember in between
shivers myself sitting there thinking
these people have done nothing to
deserve this when the UN tries to
measure how much carbon
each country in the world emits you
can't get a number for Bangladesh it's a
rounding error in the calculation they
travel by bicycle rickshaw most people
aren't connected to the electric grid
you know the four percent of us who live
in this country use twenty-five percent
of the world co2 this is not perfect
epidemiology but perhaps as moral
mathematics if therefore works to say
that one bed in four in that hospital is
on us you know and perhaps this sort of
Sunday school teacher part of me moves
from that to say that far from loving
our neighbors as we have been called to
do we're engaged in the act of sickening
drowning and otherwise making life
impossible for our neighbors around the
world with enormous speed at any rate
when I came back from Bangladesh
something in me had snapped after 20
almost 20 years of speaking and writing
about this I wanted to do something more
than that because nothing had changed in
this country we'd literally no federal
policy of any kind to address the
largest issue that had ever come down
the pike but I had no idea what I was
doing she can tell i still have little
idea either but you know I'm a writer I
live up in the woods in Vermont you know
writers are people who self-select for
like wanting to sit inside and type okay
I mean and not a not a you know I mean
we're sort of socially ill at ease and
pour it you know didn't I had no idea
really what to do my great plan I called
up a few of my other right or friends
and said look let's go up we have to do
something let's go up to Burlington our
main city and we'll sit in on the steps
of the federal building it will be
arrested and they'll be a little story
in the paper and at least we will have
done something and all these other guys
are as completely clueless as may often
okay that sounds like a good plan you
know um but happily one of them calls up
to the police and burlington's what what
happens if we the police nothing happens
you know stay there as long as you want
we'll come visit
you're not like oh okay we have to so we
had to recalibrate so I started seeing
out emails people just say we're gonna
go on a walk you know come join us in
three weeks later we leave on this walk
and we left from Robert Frost's old
summer riding cabin in the Green
Mountains because he's sort of our
patron saint in Vermont and because you
know we liked that most cliched of all
high school English class poems about
the road not taken it seemed quite
apropos to the situation so off we go
and we're walking for five days and
we're sleeping in farmer's fields along
the way and I've phoned up the kind of
Methodist mafia so we're having meetings
and churches in the evening and stuff
and it's all good we get to Burlington
there's a thousand people marching now
here's the part that I have to explain
okay in Vermont a thousand people is a
almost unbelievable number of people
okay maybe at UVM hockey games you get
that that's it like I mean people never
chose were bolting in terror from the
fence line as we came by you know I mean
it was for Vermont an impressive sight
and more than enough to get all our
candidates for office was fall 2006 to
come down and meet with us a rally on
the shore of Lake Champlain and not just
to meet with us they all signed on to
this piece of raggedy cardboard that
we've been carrying across the
countryside saying if I'm elected while
work to cut carbon emissions eighty
percent by 2050 to the time extremely
radical position the only people who
held it were scientists okay politicians
no but much too much but ok but they all
signed and not just we were pretty sure
that Bernie Sanders was going to sign
you know but but all I the woman who was
running for Congress on the GOP ticket
who was the Adjutant General of the
state national guard she had said two
months before when she launched her
campaign what so many of you all I'm not
sure that global warming is real more
research needs to be done the more
research that needed to be done was how
many people will walk across Vermont and
ask me to change my mind okay and the
empirical answer was a thousand is
enough because she signed okay was very
useful for us this was back in I you
know this was back pre Barack so we were
all still Sinha
about politics and things it was very
good for us to see the system work kind
of the way that it was supposed to the
only bummer was to open the newspaper
the next morning and there's this story
that says that this thousand people
might have represented the largest
demonstration about climate change that
had yet taken place in the United States
again all of a sudden well no wonder
we're not doing so well here you know I
mean it's true that we have economists
and scientists and politicians wonderful
leaders like Al Gore on and on and on
okay we've got all the things you need
for a movement we just forgot the
movement part you know something to give
it some heft and and wait all right so
we started thinking well maybe can we do
this outside the confines of funky
Vermont and how would we when I say we I
mean me and six students at Middlebury
College six seniors okay they were they
weren't done with school but they were
done with school so they were ready to
work here on and we didn't have any
money would any organization we just
started sending out emails to people in
January of 2007 saying will you hold a
rally with this same eighty percent man
where you are okay in April April 14 we
secretly hope that we didn't tell anyone
for fear of humiliation that we would
organize a hundred of these things and
that would have been a hundred more
turned out as Steve said an introduction
that thing just took off like a virus it
turned out there were lots of people
around the country who had cottoned on
to the essential truth that climate
change was incredibly dangerous and it
would also cotton on to the essential
truth that we were not going to solve it
one light bulb at a time okay these
people had already changed their light
bulbs they had already you know started
taking the bus they were already eating
local food already doing the sort of
things but you know they were able to do
math to at least in some visceral level
and realized that that was not change on
the scale that in the time we had was
going to do anything about actually
changing the atmospheric concentration
of co2 and so they were willing to
engage also along with all those other
good things in this kind of symbolic
political action and on that day
it was quite amazing we'd rented a halt
in DC and gotten as many politicians as
we could Corral in to watch and we just
sort of we set up the computer and a big
huge screen and people were downloading
uploading images from theirs rallies all
across the country we were just sort of
feeding them raw feed on to the wall and
they were coming in at the Times like 10
and 20 a minute from around America and
they were unbelievably beautiful to see
and we'd realized that our complete lack
of resources and organizing skill had
actually allowed something beautiful to
happen instead of having like a big
march on Washington which would have
been a little strange any way to tell
ready to drive across America to you
know protest global warming we'd had
something that was in certain ways much
sweeter than that you know people in
their own communities figuring out how
to get this message so key west florida
the only coral reefs in the u.s. you
know coral reefs in ecosystem a corner
of God's brain that will be gone by
mid-century unless we make very big
changes okay they did an underwater
demonstration they got all these people
in scuba gear and they took their signs
underwater eighty percent by coin and
big fish swimming through on the video i
mean its various like interspecies
political action is very cool and and a
little further up the coast jack I've
never been to jacksonville florida by
sense is that it's different from
vermont and the the the they chose their
place the parking lot of the NFL
football stadium okay because in the
fall i think that sort of work community
of big tailgates & think this was the
spring somebody gets it brings a yacht
there somebody else rents a crane they
winched this yacht 20 foot up in the air
and then someone said you know like ahoy
you know when when greenland slides into
the ocean there the ocean will be you
know and you can just jubail can't get
it I was in lower Manhattan and there
were thousands of people thousands of us
in blue shirts that warning everybody
holding hands dislike human tideline ok
you know New Yorkers tend to view the
world at least in part through the real
estate lens we wish to show which real
estate was going to be underwater before
long you know it was all across the
country
churches and farm fields and City Hall's
is very very beautiful and effective
three days later both Hillary Clinton
and Barack Obama changed their
environment and energy policies
dramatically and endorsed this eighty
percent by 2050 cuts okay and now you
see Obama refer to it all the time and
we see it in the congressional
legislation that was introduced by Ed
Markey and Henry Waxman day before
yesterday um it was quite nice to be
able to play a small part in that
transition in fact you could say that we
were feeling very good about ourselves
in the wake I think the technical term
would be smug in the wake of this which
is why it was quite disappointing six
weeks later when the Arctic began to
melt okay and melt very quickly and we
really were forced to realize that in
fact even eighty percent cuts by 2050
don't come close to what we need we need
much more speedy action than that and
more importantly that we need to figure
out how to do this on a global scale
very fast this is the ultimate in global
/ I don't call it global warming for
nothing okay and then we had this number
to use as a kind of tool in this
organizing project and so about a year
ago we formed this thing called 350.org
okay knowing that in December of this
year in Copenhagen the world's leaders
will meet and come up with the next big
treaty on carbon we used to think it
would be an evolutionary document that
would expand the Kyoto Accord some and
include mork now we know it has to be
given the science a really
transformative agreement it has to not
just be some agreement they'll agree on
something you know you don't get 880
heads of state in one place and say we
failed you know delegate but what we
need is an agreement that actually gets
us towards stability that takes that
number seriously so we've spent the last
year at 350.org spreading that building
a kind of networks around the world
wonderful helping find and identify and
work with wonderful
networks like the India Youth Climate
network or many others all over the
world and starting some in places where
there hasn't been this kind of thing
before we now have offices or sort of
you know we work with young people over
most of my colleagues are all 23 so
office is sometimes a sort of grand
construction but we have you know hugs
of activity in Beirut and in
Johannesburg and in Budapest and in
Delhi and in Quito and you know and in
san francisco and washington and and we
spent that year very profitably getting
this out into the bloodstream of the
kind of climate community okay moving
them some of the direction so when Al
Gore went to speak at the last big
international negotiations in Poland in
December he gave he gave the last speech
of the week and he gave us good very
good standard talk and at a certain
point because we talked with him a lot
he said and just as an aside he said and
you know what the old targets aren't
good enough we have to get to 350 and
the place just erupted is like a minute
of applause and Al Gore sarala you know
looking a little puzzled about why this
is happening we talked about it later
said you know I was pretty amazing what
had happened was that you know we'd
spread the word effectively enough
around that people understood that this
represented a real change this year
before Copenhagen we now have to take
the next step and make that into a very
public movement and that is where i need
your help okay there's an abbess as far
as I can tell no you is just talking
about this stuff unless one intends on
doing something about it October 24th is
the day we've picked for a day of global
action on 350 okay because it's about
six weeks before Copenhagen and we need
to take that most important number and
make it the most visible number in the
world and they're going to be thousands
of actions that day we sent out the
first letter about this two days ago out
around the web and we've already got two
hundred and some registered actions in
25 countries we that'll grow
exponentially as the week's go on if you
guys help they're going to be people
high up in the Himalayas with
there's going to be 350 scuba divers and
the Great Barrier Reef we just found out
that they're going to be a research team
on Easter Island and they're going to
string banners from the noses of those
stone gentlemen you know on and on and
on everything I need from you guys two
things one to organize some of those
sort of things where you are okay here
in New Haven or wherever you're from or
through whatever groups and communities
you belong to for instance around the
country churches are starting to prepare
to ring their bells 350 times on that
day okay it's a very good idea because
it turns out no TV or radio reporter can
resist coming to look when that happens
you know it's a good story you have to
explain it to the parish you have to
explain it to the neighbors and honor
you all have some overlapping
interesting sets of identities and I
need you to start thinking about how to
take those communities and put them to
work and I need one other thing we're
going to I mean look the odds on this
fight are not especially good it must be
said okay the physical momentum um
planet strong that and the other side is
extremely strong exxonmobil made more
money last year than any company in the
history of money okay um um we don't
have money as a tool we could pool what
is left of our 401ks and be somewhat
still less than Exxon Mobil you know has
all right we do have one possibility one
wild card okay and that's actually
introduced by this technology that is
spread in the last 15 or 20 years if the
internet came into being for a reason it
was to help right now right here okay if
we took the this is an interesting and
diverse curve if we took your email
address books okay and you all forwarded
this message that we've have up on the
350.org website this letter to 20 or 30
or 40 or 50 people with the little note
from yourself at the top of each one
saying
why you thought it was important okay
well not everybody who got it would open
it not everyone who act on it but if ten
percent of them did and then they
forwarded a we'd be halfway around the
world before we knew it all right that's
the only possibility we have is that
kind of virality and it is incredibly
beautiful to watch it happen I cannot
tell you how moving it is to open an
email in the morning as I did the other
morning and there's a picture from the
cameroon in west africa okay and not a
place where they have internet
connection but in the third world now
every place people have cell phones and
people know how to use them the way that
we use the net okay you can push text
and images our 90 second wordless
animation has been seen tens of millions
at times now around the world including
a lot on little tiny cell phone screens
okay well this guy the farmer there had
heard about this and understood it and
he and his neighbors planted 350 trees
on the edge of their village and hung a
little sign with this logo on it and
took a picture of it with the cell phone
and sent it to us and I damn near cried
when I saw it because a you know for
damn sure that nobody in the Cameroon is
causing global warming okay not their
fault um but also be they realized that
they can be some part of the solution to
it you know that this really is a world
and that they're going to take some
responsibility responsibility we haven't
taken to try to make something happen
the other day we got pictures from
Ladakh a small Kingdom high up in the
mountains in the Himalayas not not I
think very many Methodists in Ladakh its
Buddhists there and the buddhist
association had heard about this because
a young person behind states had been
there to visit and told about they got
very interested and they convened this
day long outdoor meeting and there were
fifteen hundred people added which turns
out to be the equivalent given the
population i mean like five million
people on the mall in washington okay
and they listened all day apparently a
94 year old man got up and gave a law
disquisition on how the weather had
changed in the course of his life and
everybody understood because the darn
glaciers are melting around and at the
end of the day is 1500 people many of
the monks and nuns formed this big human
350 the mountains in the backdrop and
unbelievably beautiful picture that's
what I need you guys to figure out how
to do we don't have if you do I mean if
I've given even the slightest impression
that were a highly organized
organization I take it back you know
there were any way a year ago we started
this six of us working full time on this
which meant that each had a continent of
their own okay um and not going to
happen if I have to or guy you have to
organize it and figure out how to push
it and just take it and run with it it's
like a potluck dinner all we're telling
you is 350 and october twenty fourth and
the rest is up to you i'm going to
finish just by I've spoken completely
frankly so far I'm going to finish by
speaking completely frankly as
absolutely no guarantee that this
strategy will work in fact there's
absolutely no guarantee any strategy
will work it is possible that we have
waited too long to get started there are
scientists who say the physical momentum
of these systems is great enough that
it's too late to meaningfully arrest
them and we're going to see the best
science indicates that there is still a
window of opportunity albeit a narrow
one albeit closing all right rajendra
pachauri the indian-born head of the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change who accepted the Nobel alongside
Gore said recently as far as he could
tell from reading the data that they're
getting that if we haven't made
fundamental changes in at least begun to
make very fundamental changes in our
energy system by 2012 okay the momentum
of these things will be too great 20 I
mean kids who entered Yale College in
last fall are going to be still in
school in 2012 okay doesn't do any good
to wait until you get out of college to
do something about
you know doesn't do any good to wait at
all that's the thing that makes it
different from any kind of movement that
we've had to build before I was thinking
about this recently because of course
we've just come through the year of the
40th anniversary of the assassination of
dr. King and so they showed off and that
incredible speech that dr. King gave the
night before he was shot that sermon in
the church in Memphis and he said I've
been to the mountaintop I've seen the
prom I don't know if I'm going to get
there with you but I know you will get
there and of course he didn't get there
with him he got gunned down the next day
nobody has to we not be as brave as
people in the civil rights movement okay
no one's going to shoot you for talking
about global warming but they had one
luxury that we didn't which was that
absolute assurance that however long it
took they would win Reverend King only
said at the end of speech is quoting
from the New England abolitionists
Theodore Parker Reverend Theodore Parker
always said the arc of the moral
universe is long but it bends toward
justice we're going to win in the end
it's a trope that Obama picked up on in
his inaugural address arc of the moral
universe is long but it bends toward
justice the Ark of the physical universe
is short and it bends toward heat and if
we do not very quickly figure out how to
get this under control then we won't it
comes with a time limit that's the bad
news the good news is that all over the
world people are beginning to figure
that out and beginning to step up and
much of its coming from young people but
it can't come from young people alone it
needs to come from every kind of people
and you have it within you to help
enormously in that process and a hope
very very much that you will and I thank
you in advance for it thank you
questions now ask if you'll feel
absolutely I'd wrists and comments or
abuse or ideas or whatever is yes should
I start over in it what you were talking
about in 2007 was eighty percent
reduction by to 2050 below 1990 levels
and I believe that some of the lot of
people talking now about reducing things
below 2005 levels which is a huge
difference and so I'd like you to come
in on that and if I know some of the
current legislation I don't think talks
about 1990 levels the other thing I
wanted to ask you about is Tim
DeChristopher who you may know of is a
university of utah student who
fraudulently been bet I mean yeah that I
guess bid sorry that's what i meant on
oil and gas leases specific with no
intention of paying for them because
specifically because he thought it would
destroy a beautiful part of the world
and specifically lead to a lot of global
warming right after that the new ken
salazar the new department head of the
department of the interior basically
nullified all of them saying basically
what Tim DeChristopher had said but the
Obama administration is still pursuing
charges against him which could result
in 10 years in jail so I wanted to know
what you think about taking more radical
action to save the plan sure it's in
this Tim DeChristopher story is a great
story a really wonderful young man who
figured out sort of almost on the spur
of the moment this quite inventive
strategy to disrupt the completely
absurd sale of oil and gas leases on the
edge of national parks and things like
that he bid he won they had this auction
you know Conoco and Chevron and stuff
and he this guy was just sitting in the
front didn't anyone like dozens of these
patches but he didn't obviously have any
money to pay for them and but it sort of
threw a monkey wrench as it were into
the whole thing and as you point out the
Obama
administration as soon as it got in over
turn these sales it's not the Obama
administration that's in daiting him
it's the leftover US attorney from the
Bush administration in Utah who is
apparently getting ready to run for
Congress and determined to make a name
for himself on this guy I sought Tim in
and this goes to your question about
more radical action saw Tim in DC three
weeks ago where we did this protest when
you all must know Wendell Berry the
great Kentucky a farmer and author and I
think the finest writer at work in our
country today he and I had sent out a
letter asking people to come to DC for
civil disobedience outside turns out the
Congress operates its own coal-fired
power plant two blocks from Capitol Hill
for 103 years it's been burning coal
it's in complete violation of the Clean
Air Act and everything else but um so we
asked people to come join what Tim was
one of the people who came it was a
beautiful great inspiring day we all I
had Wendell Berry on one arm and Jim
Hansen on the other and there was Terry
tempest Williams you know and all kinds
of other people were all down there
illegally oh the police there's so many
people showed up that the police decided
not to arrest anyone because they
couldn't deal with the number of people
that showed up and Nancy Pelosi and
Harry Reid announced that they were
going to stop burning coal in this power
plant and start burning something else
you know so it was pretty it was pretty
cool day and a validation of this that
we might need more no more radical
action more all kinds of creative action
um one of the things to get to make sure
you get your head around in this global
warming debate by the way is the meaning
of that word radical all right what's
radical almost inconceivably radical is
pouring more carbon into the atmosphere
and just seeing what happens okay
melting the Arctic is about as radical
and act is you could think of all right
and frankly those of us who are fighting
it are profoundly conservative in
every meaningful sense of that word all
right i mean the basic argument is this
worked reasonably well for 10,000 years
let's see if we can keep it going a
little longer all right that's a
conservative principle if there ever was
one I think at the moment what we most
need is this kind of symbolic action of
the type that we're talking about it 350
all right we're not going to close down
one by one all the coal plants in the
country and and then in the world in
time enough to make a difference our
hope for making a palpable difference in
the amount of carbon that goes into the
atmosphere is reaching national and then
global agreements to put stiff caps on
carbon and begin to ratchet those caps
down that's the only place we have for
there's enough leverage to actually move
things quickly that's why this you know
kind of action that we're doing this
with globally coordinated thing at 350
and potentially is very useful it sets a
bar for those negotiators as they arrive
in Copenhagen it focuses the somehow
getting ahold of the imagination of the
world is the most important thing if you
can do that if you can get people
understanding thinking along the same
particular line not that we need to do
something about the environment but that
this is what this is how the world works
that that's as much carbon as we can
have then you can bend that that
perception will then work to one degree
or another to really bend the politics
that's got to be the hope anyway Oh
question about co2 levels in 1990 and
2005 and yeah this stuff ships all the
time it's not worrying about the exact
target that you're aiming for any
particular moment is not the key
question is can we get huge action
started on climate okay because even the
most ambitious numbers that we talk
about probably aren't enough to do what
needs to be done what we need to do is
get this process going in a bit
big way fast and then see how much we
can speed it up along the way okay so
and and for that the most useful thing
is to have a real goal in mind and that
goal has to be to bring the carbon
concentration in the atmosphere back now
that's an you know it's going to be the
youngest people in this room will be
elderly before that happens under the
best of circumstances okay but if we
don't start now then no one will ever
see that concentration again because the
momentum will get too strong that's why
we have start now I've gone on too long
here's one back here and then one over
here yes may I ask and i'll try to you
through as the time if you keep your
questions brief and focus that'll help
all rattle on that's the real problem
here i understand hi i'm going to play
devil's advocate please so if humans are
good at anything it's adapting if we can
have a green revolution if China can
rebuild its economy in 30 years we will
figure this out one way or another I
mean Obama right now it's at g20 saying
you know yeah this is going to take
leadership we all these great activists
running around why should I care okay
very good question and defines where
most people are the first thing to
understand is that there are limits to
adaptation okay and we're now pushing
those limits of adaptation hard and
we're quite adaptable but we're you know
think about well think about Bangladesh
it just as a proxy for thousands of
other places around the world okay I'll
try to imagine what adaptation might
mean when sea level has risen a couple
of feet and there's no water coming down
from the Himalayas everybody who models
the scenario says what it means is 50 60
70 80 90 million people trying to find
someplace else to live okay well try to
model that adaptation because human
beings do move where are they planning
to move
india's next door it's really not like
india has you know just a vast
unexplored frontier you know to just
poor people into in fact india is
finishing building this year a 2500 mile
long wall modeled on the one between
Israel and the West Bank electrified in
portions between India and Bangladesh
precisely to keep people from coming
across it okay I'll think about
adaptation to an ocean where the pH has
changed from 8.2 to 8.1 in the last
decade or so all right becoming steadily
more acidic and already reaching the
point where the small animals that make
up the single biggest part of the
world's biomass are unable to form their
shells in that acid environment think
about adaptation in a place like
California Steven Chu the new energy
secretary the no belliston physics okay
went to his native California to give he
gave his first interview since taking
office and since he's a scientist by
training he hasn't yet and hopefully
never will learn the you know political
art of pulling his punches you know what
he said in the interview with the Los
Angeles Times was I don't think you guys
have quite understood in your gut what's
going on said the modeling shows unless
we make big changes by later in this
century there will be no snow pack left
in the Sierras at which point they'll be
no agriculture in California and I'm not
sure you'll be able to live in the big
cities either okay there were the point
I'm trying to make is there are limits
to adaptability given very long time you
can adapt to a lot right the oceans rise
and fall over deep time and against that
an increase in sea level of a foot
doesn't you know to Allah we could I
don't know an increase in sea level on
the east coast where much beaches slope
inward at one degree one foot more ocean
brings the water 90 feet further in you
know um
there comes a point and it's not that
far away at which it's very difficult to
mean the US government even in the bush
administration published study last year
saying that a two-foot rise in sea level
would mean that you'd have to rebuild or
move all the airports or most of the
airports on the eastern seaboard you
know on and on and on one of the ways to
understand this is that there's not
enough money in the world to adapt to
the kind of changes that are coming all
right we're getting used to tossing
around trillion dollar figures okay
there's a lot more trillions out there
to toss around I mean one hurricane one
hurricane across one relatively small
area New Orleans and coastal Mississippi
took so far stake about a hundred and
forty billion dollars to fix and those
of you who've been down there know that
it's far from fixed at that price you
know um um so it's very important to
figure out how to adapt to that which we
can't stop but we've got to keep things
I mean all the things that I've
described today remember this may be the
most useful statistic to keep in mind
all the changes that I've described
today the Arctic melon that's with a one
degree Fahrenheit increase in global
average temperature from 59 to 60
degrees the consensus estimate by no
means the worst-case estimate by at this
point in fact even a conservative one is
that by the end of this century unless
we do dramatic things we will have
raised the temperature five degrees
further from what it is now okay and you
don't just get to x 5 the kind of damage
we're seeing because what we're now
understanding is that the planet works
in the threshold steps and you go past a
certain one of them and big things not a
smooth linear acceleration so I got to
say the most important adaptation that
we need to make is to get off fossil
fuel as fast as we can so that we don't
make this problem any worse than it
already is believe me there's already
more than enough to adapt to coming down
the pipeline everybody I mean everybody
on the one hand is outraged you know and
the question is is exactly as you put it
is
uring out what do we do at any given
moment that's the most effective use of
that outrage passion anger and also joy
and hope and and love you know because
those are at least as important one of
the things that we need to do is is
deploy that outrage as effectively as
possible okay one of the best things
about this thing we did in DC when
Wendell Berry and I had been planning it
one of the things we told everybody is
if you want to come get arrested you
have to come wearing your you know
Sunday best or whatever okay um because
a we wanted to point out that we were
not strange radical force that were very
in a certain sense are very conservative
1 and B because there's always the
danger in this kind of work that
there'll be a kind of just unhinged
anger and whatever that takes over in
people protesting in ways that the rest
of the world can't understand and
doesn't make sense you know and and we
saw some of that in London you know I
don't think anybody can really explain
exactly what everybody was rampaging
around London about those people who
were protesting the last few days and it
completely got overwhelmed by the much
more positive pictures of you know
Michelle bless her heart with you know
young school kids and things you know um
I mean it was very cool um this question
of what's most effective haunts me all
the time I think is that you can tell
from where I'm spending my work I do i
do I will continue to work on civil
disobedience toughening sins appropriate
I think the thing for the moment for
this year is this very insistent
symbolic action that we take seriously
the science there are exceptions to that
and they're people organizing wonderful
stuff among other things in the coal
fields of West Virginia and Kentucky
global warming I mean if you want to see
a vision of hell
is it mountaintop removal zones of the
southern Appalachians you know where the
coal that we use to power our lives is
literally I mean when they say
mountaintop removal it's exactly what
they mean you know they are in fact my
one of my favorite there was a guy down
there a pastor who was sort of heading
some of the opposition to this and you
know those church signs they have in
rural areas we had changed the letters
in front of me we can put some corn easy
his one week he put up sign that said um
said God was wrong support mountaintop
removal you know I mean it's I mean it's
it's it's beyond belief the the scale of
devastation and so I'm going down there
to help people work in ethics but I
think in our communities right now most
important thing is to take that message
and virally spread it as far as we can
and you know it's going to happen or not
going to happen based in part on the
ability of people who are especially
people who are talented using these new
tools that we have to spread that stuff
all of you who know how to use email are
extremely powerful at this point that's
our odd new invention okay and people
who are good at political action over
the years have always taken advantage of
new inventions television when it came
into being was the thing that allowed
dr. King to do much of what he did you
know on and on and on this is our wild
card I think we've got time for one more
if it's quick if there's someone mary
evelyn amazing work for so long and i
just want it as to what students are
thinking about and that that is that the
forum on religion and ecology is
completely with you we do have eight
thousand people on this list its
international and we will help your
wonderful bloodstream but I also just
want to say that the website is based
here at Yale and we are putting up on
the website all of the major statements
of the world's religions on
change up and I think our call is to
call them to action many terrific
stations have been made by the world yes
but we will certainly help you and this
is maria von a thank you so much for
that if there's any person in the world
who's going to be able to leverage the
faith communities of the world behind
this action it's Mary Ellen John who
have done unbelievable work over the
years and all of that and in what she
said what you said at the end is
absolutely right you know every
denomination that we can think of now
has passed some kind of resolution
saying we believe in Stuart in God's
creation and you know you know and maybe
they've even gone and changed some of
the light bulbs in the sanctuary okay
it's not working you know and the time
has come to everybody for each of us to
sort of call our own bluffs on this and
say okay you know now where am I ready
to go it's funny I was speaking last
night in Mount Holyoke College and I was
in a wood room of undergraduates okay
and I was thinking I just sort of struck
me because I've been thinking a lot
about the civil rights movement stuff
you know that these were you know 50
years ago in that same room there
doubtless were young women sitting there
trying to figure out if they were going
to get on the bus to go to Alabama or
Mississippi or whatever it was you know
and whether they had the courage and the
willingness to set aside some of the
sort of path in front of them for a
while or whatever else to make that
happen okay and they were you know along
with the people who did far more in the
south to begin with you know they were
among the reasons that we were able to
in the 1960s see such a great change in
consciousness a change in consciousness
that continues to bear fruit absent that
movement know barack obama in you know
2009
um um that's the kind of moment that
we're at they don't come along all that
often and it's kind of a pain when they
do because people who know about things
become morally obliged to do something
about them and if they don't then
there's a kind of rot that sets in and
um um I really look forward to working
with all you on this going forward thank
you